thank you Candace
thank you Candace welcome everyone so
what's next after kubernetes
um is that a uh audacious question do we
dare ask uh you know I think kubernetes
is such a massive force on um many of us
and it has had a massive impact on the
industry as a whole
uh do we dare ask but I think if you're
here you're probably as curious as I am
as as to what is it next after
kubernetes so in this talk I'm going to
show you an example of something that
we've been doing my company that is kind
of next after kubernetes
but I'll give you a hint it's it's
kubernetes less and it's take that for
what what it means and we'll get back to
that so before getting into some of more
of the details I think it's pretty
important to position things and I I
honestly kind of think of the where
we're at today and where we have been
for a few years is we're in the the
kubernetes era and I'm talking from the
perspective of back end systems
typically running in the cloud or you
know some highly virtualized environment
but you know there's kind of we're in
this Epoch or era of the kubernetes time
and I think we're well entrenched in
that time right now kubernetes has been
around for for a while and it was highly
adopted as it should be so there's these
three eras you know there's
pre-kubernetes there's kubernetes and
then there's post kubernetes I'll be
focusing on post kubernetes but
pre-kubernetes is you know we're we're
doing things without kubernetes we're
doing that for I've been in the business
for a long time we've been doing things
that evolved at a certain pace
um for a long time before kubernetes
came around but then wow when kubernetes
came it was uh it was just a fantastic
thing for us to adopt and many many of
you us have have adopted it and then now
we're starting to build on top of that
and so that's where I think things are
heading
so uh to kind of and what I mean by
many of much of this is that we're kind
of dealing with abstraction layers so
this visualization here I just want to
use this to to talk a little bit about
some of the abstraction layers and the
just the concept of of the of the
abstracting things away uh as time goes
on
so there's like six layers here and I've
I've just added some labels these are
just arbitrary labels that I had you
know I picked
um we could label this many many
different ways but just I've just wanted
to kind of go through the gauntlet of
some of the the layers of um
infrastructure and technology that we
depend on to run our systems and the
abstraction layers that uh kind of
intersect as we go up up the stack here
starting at the bottom you know there's
the hardware and you know just where we
do Computing actual physical devices
that we use to do computing
when I started you know I've been around
a bit
um that's what it what we use we use the
physical Hardware but then Along Came
virtualization that was great it was a
it was a a great abstraction leader uh
and it was a kind of a what I'll call a
hired abstraction layer meaning that
when we were allocated my teams that I
worked on you know or you if you're
using it as well when we're allocated
virtual systems we had no idea what the
actual physical devices that these
virtualized servers and virtualized
devices were running on and we didn't
really care so there was this kind of
hard abstraction layer that okay we
lived in the virtual environment and we
were quite happy with that
now stepping way up to kubernetes
that changes the game again big jump in
abstraction and again it's a it's a hard
abstraction layer where we
run our applications in the kubernetes
environment it gives us all the
wonderful things and capabilities and
you know features that come along with
kubernetes vastly Superior to say just
uh you know what we had prior to
kubernetes and it's a hard abstraction
leader we're quite happy to be there we
we understand how to use kubernetes to
run our applications and we're good with
that now of course people are some
people are having to deal with the the
inner workings you know kind of what
what's in the Black Box uh of the of the
kubernetes environment but there's a
clean kind of separation between those
that are using what's on top versus
those that are maintaining what what's
Within
and then stepping up another layer
containers and I know kubernetes is
really there to kind of manage
containers is one way to look at it in
containers I think preceded kubernetes
um you know to a certain extent but it's
just kind of enough uh for the sake of
this discussion it's another layer of
abstraction the container is nicely
Embraces the application code and
shelters it from the outside world that
it gives us this you know the
applications facade of this these are
the libraries that's using this is the
flavor of to say you know of the
operating system that we're using those
types of things so it isolates our
application code
stepping up another layer we've got
services and by service is what I mean
are things like databases and message
Brokers you know and uh security and say
single sign-on and there's just you know
tons and tons of different services that
different applications depend on in
order to you know actually be completely
functional and then finally the top
layer is the application layer now
what kubernetes did is like I said it's
a hard extraction layer that we we
really don't uh need to deal with what's
below that abstraction level the vast
majority of people that is that is using
kubernetes and those layers are still
there so this is the kind of the the
less thing is virtual system lists it's
Hardware less even though you know it's
serverless in a way
um because the the servers are
abstracted away from the users
especially the development teams and
this is you know my background the
people that are trying to get things
running within the kubernetes
environment
what's next though I think is really
taking another big jump and this is
abstracting away even more complexity
because one of the phenomenons that has
happened I think recently especially
like with with devops and and so on is
that
um and trimming things down and you know
making things easier to a certain extent
a lot of responsibility for dealing with
the uh the infrastructure that was left
you know it's great abstraction with the
kubernetes and these Services was fell
on the uh the development teams and
we're kind of drowning in complexity is
is one way that um
that one way to think about it and that
we have to figure out okay what database
we're going to use what message broker
can we use what how are we going to
tweak this how are we going to run you
know how we're going to use kubernetes
how we're going to do all these
different things and then by the way oh
yeah we got to write the application
we've got to implement the features that
the business and the users are asking
for so a lot of our time in development
teams is spent not just cranking on
features that matter to your users
matter to the business but also dealing
with you know the environment that the
application is going to run in
this next evolutionary jump I think is
trying to abstract away a lot more of
that complexity
now
uh this is a big change and I'm gonna go
into it of course into some more detail
but I I just wanted to bring this up
because there's this great video that if
you haven't seen it I highly recommend
you watch it it's on YouTube the title
is down here the at the bottom of Brett
Victor of the future programming it's
it's one of the most amazing uh
presentations I've ever seen it was done
in 2013 so it's 10 years old but it's
still I think highly relevant you can
see that he's dressed and he's actually
presenting in 2013 he's talking about
he's as if he was talking from the 70s
from 73 he's dressed as a developer from
73 you can actually see that he's got a
pocket protector in so he played the
role of a developer predicting what
Computing would be like in 40 years in
2013.
um and one of the things he mentioned in
this talk that really I think is
relevant to to this discussion is that
he was talking about in the early days
of programming first the pro program
programmers coded in binary and they got
comfortable with that they're quite
happy with that and then all of a sudden
somebody came along and introduced
Assembly Language
um symbolic optimized uh assembly
programming I think is what that acronym
soap stands for anyways it's Assembly
Language and there was a lot of pushback
because it was new the people that were
comfortable with binaries like why do I
need this Assembly Language because I'm
losing control I have total control of
the hardware at the the binary level so
there was pushback this is aversion to
change
and then
we settled into Assembly Language after
you know some whining and crying and
finally started to get some adoption but
didn't take too long before yet another
wave of abstraction came along here
programming abstraction and the one he
shows here is Fortune so Fortran comes
along oh you know the assembling against
program is all going nah what I don't
you know I'm losing control I can't I
don't I'm not going to use that you know
like I can do whatever I want in some of
the language
his point is that
um there there is this aversion as these
new waves of abstraction are introduced
there's we have to go through this
change and change is something that we
resist and we often find to be painful
and I I think if you're here if you're
listening to this talk you're probably
not necessarily in that group but I like
the points that that Mr Victor made here
because I use it for ammunition when I'm
talking to other people so maybe you
could use this to talk when you're
talking to other people when you're
trying to convince them to try something
new
so uh what I want to do is just jump
quickly into uh before I show you like
what this abstraction layer is I just
want to show you an example of an app
that I build
using this abstraction layer and it's an
app I call
where on earth and the way it works is
that I wrote it I wrote the front end
it's just some JavaScript and then they
wrote the back end in the subscript this
this highly abstract uh layer of that
I'll show you some more details in a
minute
but it's based on open street maps I can
um you know zoom into a certain area of
the world
and what I can do is create simulated
iot devices
and as I zoom in you can see that
there's these regions there's these
circular regions where there are devices
that have been created
and um
you know so I what I you know so what
happens here is that um let me pick
another part of the I'm just going to
pick kind of another
area here and I'll just show you a quick
example so like you can zoom in onto an
area of the map uh we're just picking
another city here
um
and I can create what's called a
generator and I pick a location
then I pick a radius like this is the
area that I want to create devices in
then I can pick the number of devices I
want to create
NRA make around say like 1500 or so and
then I can pick a rate and say like 500
per second so it's going to go pretty
quick
so then I send in a request to the back
end service back in microservices that
I'll show you what there are in a moment
and then this is triggering a whole kind
of event driven type of sequence of
events and you can see the devices start
to appear on the screen at the rate that
I asked for so the devices are created
and then there's a kind of another
process of aggregation that's occurring
that takes a little bit more time
where it's going to be computing
where devices are you know how many
devices are in a given region on the map
and you can see it is starting to appear
here on the map as there as they're
getting computed but this aggregation is
also happening through kind of an event
driven type of a process and
um you and you can kind of see it all
happening real time this is the fun part
of this application this is a really fun
application to write
now the the tricky part was that this
aggregation has to happen at uh 20
levels of Zoom there's uh like zoom
level 19 is where devices are at in Zoom
zero is where is that the the whole
world so as I zoom out you can see where
you know there's devices across the
whole world
and this aggregation is happening now
you know as as uh the Computing is going
on you can see more and more of these
aggregated regions are showing up
anyways this is the app
could spend a whole hour just talking
about this uh this app now it's it's
written in in this case it's written in
Java this this environment is polyglot
but I've done it in Java and it's using
spring like notation so the API is quite
simple this is the generator
microservices I call it and this is the
one that got the request to create a new
generator with it with the location
the radius the number of devices to be
created and the rate
so this generator then started emitting
events which trigger the actual process
of creation and uh I wish I had more
time to explain how it works but it's
pretty pretty cool but the point I want
to make is that
this is running in a highly abstract
layer where it's even databaseless and
that you know say this this command is
coming into this microservice
and you can see that I'm just doing a
getting an event for it this is just a
method I wrote for this command so given
the current state of this device which
in this case the device is brand new so
it has no State the create command comes
in and that's going to trigger uh
creating an event which gets persisted
by this return so this effects dot emit
events then reply is basically uh
handing back to the platform that this
is running on here's an event that I
would like you to persist and then
process further down the line so there's
no database connections here there's no
database transactions here there's no
serialization or deserialization here
handling the incoming requests or
sending back the response
um it's just it's simplified
so this is the the whole idea of this
kind of coding here is that you know the
code is fairly simple here the only
complicated code here is kind of
figuring out the uh the actual random
location of devices using doing some
latitude latitude and longitude type of
uh of computations but that's the
business logic but the integration with
the you know the persistence layer
handling events and so on is all handled
by the platform
um and the the code is quite simple so
um this I'll give you the link to this
project but um it it's pretty
straightforward
um
the uh
the other thing is I want to move on
here
so this is the actual kind of high level
design of this application that you know
that there was that client UI written in
JavaScript that had that open street map
integration you know in the in the
JavaScript code but basically what I did
was when I created
um a generator was I
captured all that data using the user
interface and then sent a single request
to a
a generator microservice
is uh that received the request to
create a a new generator so that new
generator gets created
and it's emitting a quite a few events
um kind of on uh repeatedly where it's
triggering the creation of devices
and these events that are coming out of
the generator are triggering ultimately
results in sending individual messages
to each of the 1500 or so devices that I
just created so a lot of Eventing
happened in the system where it was
creating all these devices
and then as devices are getting created
they're emitting events which are
getting handled by
another microservice they call region
the region is those those rectangular
areas on the map where it's aggregating
the data and the reason I have kind of
this loopback event is that what's
happening is that a device tells its
region that it's within hey I'm here I'm
a new device you need to aggregate you
need to add me to your account
that region then is at a certain zoom
level and it then it what it needs to do
is propagate a higher level kind of
aggregated event up to its parent region
and that propagates from
19 zoom level 19 where the devices are
at to 18 were the first you know real
physical region is that and it goes all
the way up to zero so there's a venting
that's just kind of propagating all the
way up this is the way I made this app
work you could do it differently but the
point is it was this is all just done to
event-driven types of integration the
client it just sent in that single
request gotta you know to say create a
generator got a response back you have
to generate is created and then what the
client is doing is this polling uh use
these little V's I represent as views
and I'll get into a little bit more
detail on what what all these symbols
being here but this is basically how
this app worked it's a fun little event
driven type of application highly
scalable
highly distributed runs in clusters and
all those types of things I don't care
about that as a developer what I care
about is the design and implementation
of my application and then I deploy it I
basically give my application to the the
platform and say platform run my
application which means it's going to
set up everything I need like the the
databases that are underlying this
application everything gets set up
that's all abstracted away from me as a
developer I'm just kind of concerned
about my code
here's another example app you can see
there's also a link down to this GitHub
repo for those that are interested
um and it's another event driven type of
an app
and I'll get into a little bit more
detail on this one as well but before I
get into it I want to kind of explain
um some of the
pieces of this uh
this abstraction layer so it's it's
quite simple it starts out with projects
you define projects within this um you
know this abstraction layer and projects
you can have any number of projects and
you can use projects in whatever way you
want so some projects could be just free
for you for development or for your team
for doing you know team development or
another project could be for testing or
performance testing or whatever you want
to do and then some projects are of
course for production each project you
can control who has access to those
things are highly secure especially this
is of course very important for
production
but you have control over what you do
with your projects you meet you know you
manage the project within this
environment
when it within each project there's just
simple deployments so they're you know
um they're called services and but I
like to call on deployments because
that's really what they are as far as
I'm concerned and uh you can have any
number of services one or more services
within a project and uh and these these
services are are self-contained
independent of each other I mean they're
deployed independently
um
but they can interact with each other of
course as well
and then within the deployments there
are three building block components
there is what's called an entity but I
think these more as a as a tight focused
microservice
and then there's views with this
v-shaped and these are queryable views
and and the reason what's going on here
is entities are responsible for like I
said they're microservices they're
responsible for handling commands or
requests to do some operation coming in
they perform some kind of a state change
operation and there's two flavors of uh
of these there's one that's event
sourcing where it emits events and then
another one is more crud-like it's like
a key value thing where it just submits
the current state change to be persisted
into a state store
but I I'm I think there's much more
value and usage of the uh the Eventing
ones the the event sourcing ones so if
you're familiar with event sourcing or
event sourcing and then go typically
what goes along with that or what event
sourcing is typically part of is cqs or
command query responsibility segregation
and what that means is that entities or
these microservices are only focused on
writing data they're not focused on
reading it now you can retrieve in like
individual things like the state of an
individual iot device or the state of an
individual shopping cart or an order or
something like that whatever it happens
to be your design
but the views are for reading and this
is the segregation piece the writing
happens in one place reading happens in
another place they're separated from
each other so the views are there to
take the data that's coming from
the microservices and project goes into
queryable views so this is the cqrs part
and that's built into this platform so
those that's two of the three building
block components within this platform
the third one is a real Workhorse and
it's called an action but it's a you can
think of it as like a stateless
serverless function
but I it's I think it's that's almost
kind of um not giving in enough credit
because you can do you do so much with
these actions but they're like the
synaptic connection between uh event
flows you know and and I'll show you how
that works in a minute but these are the
three building blocks I'm amazed how
much I can do with this as a developer
and it I also like the fact that it kind
of keeps me within uh some guardrails as
far as how I develop things because of
the the way these things work because it
you might think initially again
um
uh every time I have that original I
can't use this I've done this over and
over and over in my career and now I'm
at to the point whenever that instinct
kicks in I know I need to polarize it to
the opposite end meaning that instead of
just dismissing this because it's like
oh man I can't use this I need all the
flexibility it's like no no no Hugh
you're wrong your instincts are wrong
you go with it and uh so I'm not just
like I gotta check it you know when I
hear something new instead of just
immediately dismissing it I typically
try and check it out before I just
outright dismiss it
I think in this case the payoff's pretty
high because
I was I've been talking about as a as a
developer Advocate and I speak at
conferences all over the world and I've
been doing it for for some years now and
I've been one of the things I've been
talking about for a long time is
microservice systems and one of the
things I've been talking about with
microservices the microservices should
be
folk the East microservice should do one
thing and do it well each microservice
should own its own data and not expose
that data to anything outside of the
microservice other than through its API
each microservice should be Loosely
coupled and now I finally feel like I've
got a tool that formalizes a lot of
these practices and makes it hard for
developers not to do some of the things
that all many of us have been trying to
evangelize the development community and
of course is being adopted by some of
the development Community but
the microservice environment over the
last you know almost a decade now has
been pretty Wild and Woolly and it's you
know it's it's loose I think in many
cases how how we've been doing things
but we've been trying to save you know
tight Focus
on your data Loosely coupled all that
good stuff and here that this is exactly
how this system works so in this in the
case of a disorder processing demo I
just want to walk through the invention
very quickly so you got a client that's
you know interacting with a shopping
cart you know I got a shopping cart you
get a shopping cart other users that are
currently active on the system right now
each one of us has our own shopping cart
it's a unit of state that's being
managed by the back end system we're
sending in commands from the client you
know via requests to shopping cart add
an item change an item remove an item
whatever we're building up each each of
our shopping carts hopefully from the
perspective of the business that's
running this you know this online
shopping site people hit the buy button
and they they check out the order
when orders are checked out
that Microsoft said shopping cart
microservice emits an event that's
picked up by an action you know those
that stateless serverless function which
translates to events you know uh
shopping cart created say event and it
creates it transforms that into a create
order command and uh fires that command
off at uh at the order microservice and
now an order is created
now the the client sent in that single
request and the response back went to
the clients if yep your order is checked
out we're working on it so the client's
gone at this point but this one single
event this checkout event is is going to
trigger
a pretty elaborate uh cascading sequence
of events here that that's kind of cool
so the order gets created
when it gets created it makes an event
that's actually being picked up by two
different actions and one is an order
item which is just kind of there for
query so it's not really important but
the another one is a shipping order so
the difference between at least this is
my design don't have to be doesn't have
to be done this way I know this isn't a
real system but it's it was a fun demo
to do is more than just a simple
shopping cart demo which I was getting
sick and tired of of doing just that I
wanted to do something more real like
allocate stock to an order so that's
what this is working towards so the
shipping order is trying is responsible
for getting stock allocated to the order
the order tracks the order through
um its full life cycle that's what these
two different you know order does and
shipping order does
so an order gets created and it's an
event it creates it causes the creation
of a of a shipping order when a shipping
order gets created it creates an event
that actually
um explodes out into creating multiple
order SKU items for all these items in
in the shopping cart in the order
and when each of those individual orders
skew items gets created guess what they
admit event which gets picked up by uh
stock but in this case the actions doing
a little bit more interesting work
instead of just transforming an event
into command what it first does is a
query against a stock View and what it's
looking for is stock that's available
it gets that response back from the
query and if there is stock available
then it will create a command to send to
say allocate stock to a particular order
allocate a particular unit of stock to a
particular order unit of stock if there
isn't
sufficient stock available for that SKU
this action I don't have it an Arrow
showing it but it would actually send a
command back to that order because you
random say hey put yourself in a back
order State because we don't have
sufficient stock right now
so there's a bit of a saga-like pattern
going on here again
a lot of detail here that I we just
don't have the love of your time to
cover here but
um it goes through the processing
so all this Eventing occurs you know
that that ultimately ends up notifying
the order that uh you know either all
the stock has been allocated and the
order is ready to ship or some of it's
some or all of it's on in a back order
state that type of thing all done
through Eventing
um the all of the Eventing is being
managed by the platform all the
messaging all the you know for for me
for you as a developer we're just
writing the uh the the microservices
we're writing the code for that we're
writing the code for the views we're
running the code for the actions that's
it
events are being passed to actions by
the platform you don't have to
explicitly write code to retrieve events
from the you know the event journals say
from the Upstream thing that you want
you just declare in your code through an
annotation in Java that you know my my
Event Source is from uh like in shipping
that shipping order action you know the
order to shipping order action it just
declares through an annotation saying
Hey My My Event Source is ordered you
know give me events from there that's
all I all you have to do it's a kind of
a declarative type of thing
so back on the that we're on Earth I
just wanted to show you a little bit
more detail and I'll go through this
quickly because we're running out of
time but this is a kind of a more
detailed breakdown of the processing
that happens at the demo like I call it
where on Earth woe so the idea is that
you know the client said to generate um
you know create a generator the
generator gets created and it's an event
that those of that event gets picked up
and propagated into a view but also gets
picked up by some actions you can see
one action's actually going back to the
generator so there's kind of a loopback
that's occurring here and what's
Happening Here is this loopback is just
telling the generator right you
generated some of the devices that are
needed per unit at a time here's your
next unit of time you know generate the
next quantity of devices based on the
kind of like the current time so it's
just kind of a loopback that keeps
triggering the the generator to keep
generating stuff until it's done and
then that Loop setback cycle will happen
conversely what's happening is that
the generator is generating events that
ultimately result in an action sending
commands to individual devices like the
1500 devices I created there were 1500
commands that were sent out to create
all those devices
and that just kind of loops around until
all the devices are created as devices
are created they emit events that are
getting picked up and it goes to a
region
the region of instant events that kind
of keeps looping back and um yeah you
know to go up the different Zoom levels
up the stack of Zoom levels that were in
the map to do that aggregation of all
the data that's arriving there's some
dampening that occurs so that the you
know the zoom level zero isn't getting
like 1500 mess you know commands it's
getting far less than that because it's
kind of like uh what happens is in this
aggregation flow that occurs through
this Eventing there's kind of a flood of
events that are coming in at the lowest
level zooms but then it kind of gets
down to a trickle as it gets to the you
know like to the top level
um region for the entire world
and then the client is just querying the
views so all the data that we're look
that we're looking at on the map is
coming from the views that were
ultimately updated from as a result of
all these all of all this Eventing that
occurred
so that loops around for a bit and um
you know we're uh we're done
um another app and I'm actually working
on this one right now I've got the
design worked out and it's actually kind
of my second iteration on the design uh
uh and implementations like I'm I'm
re-implementing it with this kind of new
design it's a simplification of my prior
design but the fun part
is that I really enjoyed as a developer
and as a say an architect or designer is
thinking through the Eventing process
here and what
one of the interesting mechanical
aspects of this that you have to
consider is that all of the Eventing all
of the messaging that occurs here is a
guarantee at least one's delivery
which is great that means that every
single event
that I want to trigger an action to
perform some kind of operation to send a
command Downstream to another
microservice
I know will happen it'll at some point
it will happen it might not happen
immediately it might happen with you
know very very quickly it typically does
within milliseconds but it could not
happen until tomorrow if there was an
outage or something or seconds later if
something slowed or or if the network
burped or something like that but all
these messages are guaranteed to be
delivered because this is at least one
slippery that's typically what you get
was you know any kind of um you know
message broker but that also comes with
a consideration of item potency and item
potency is that each of the receivers of
in these incoming messages
have to be able to handle getting the
same message more than once and that
will give you pause as you're
considering the design it will I I will
guarantee you because I've been dealing
with this for a year now myself
um kind of heads down all the time
is working through designs where you
have have this at least once message
guarantee delivery guarantee which is
great but you've got to build your
services to be item potent
that's a new thing typically we haven't
had to deal with that as Developers but
it when you do it it's a thing of beauty
because you've got you end up having a
robust robust system anything can break
here any part of this flow that's
occurring here in this case what this
application is doing is what it's
designed for is this topic that is
consuming messages from that are flowing
into this transaction microservice is
high volume it's like thousands of
messages are coming off of a Kafka topic
per second the system has to be able to
consume all those messages and aggregate
that data into what are called Merchant
payments so the What's Happening Here is
that there's a there's a flood of data
coming in you know every second into
this system and it's stepping down kind
of like what I did with these Zoom
levels in the region
this this
um microservice I call interval is
handling data at time intervals so
initially it handles data at a sub
second interval and subsequent intervals
feed into second intervals and second
intervals feed into minute intervals and
minute intervals to hour and hour today
and then day intervals their events are
being watched for in this action right
before the merchants
and it's feeding as the days are getting
updated with Merchant specific
uh aggregated data you know sums of of
uh transaction activity that need to be
uh
sent out as payments to the merchant or
Merchant payments that the merchant has
to make to other entities for service
charges and things like that
um
that flow is quite low at the day end
because it's been kind of stepped down
through the through a series of
aggregation but this is money right so
no data can be lost nothing can get
corrupted and it was very important to
consider things like item potency in a
system like this
but this system what happened what's
happening then is the merchants emitting
events as days are getting updated and
those those days are just going to
payments the current payment for the
current payment cycle and we're just
aggregating continuously in real time
and whenever uh payments have a certain
time cycle it could be hours it could be
days it could be weeks it could be
whatever you know whatever the um the
receiver of the payments want them to be
but when the the payment cycle is done
we just shut off the flow to one payment
the merchant does this from one payment
and the flow immediately switches over
to another payment so there's no uh the
system is a uh
often done in a in a batch way where
when you want a payment you trigger a
whole batch kind of activity where
you're trying to accumulate a lot of the
data that's been then that has been come
has come in over time and you want to do
it as quickly as possible to bring out a
payment this system does it in real time
again it's rock solid because of the
least once delivery and being very
careful to Divine Design the services to
be item potent
so this is an example of this new
abstraction layer
um again I wish I had more time but the
you know the main thing is like it's
trying to cut out as much complexity as
possible and leave us with the really
important stuff which is design of these
applications which is a really fun
intellectual uh challenge to and and one
that's great when you're you you're not
uh distracted with all the other
Technologies things that we historically
have had to deal with I I feel liberated
honestly we're not working on this uh I
tell people I don't want to go back to
the old ways of doing things I love
kubernetes I it was a it's a great
invention but I don't want to go back
and start dealing with the ammo files
again I you know I'm sick and tired of
coding uh configurations in yaml files
in this system there's zero
configuration my configurations is
defined in my code how I wired things
together how I wire these Services
together is basically defined in code
and that's it I'm done
um
the another thing just again I as you
can tell I'm a big fan of this talk but
early on in this talk
[Music]
um
uh Brett made two made a really
interesting point
he said it's easy to adopt new
technologies but if being hired to adopt
new ways of thinking
and he hammers on this and I just
noticed this but if you look at this
picture he's got that pocket detector
and he's got this one uh pencil sticking
up I don't know if he's given us a
salute or not because he he's I think
he's
um admonishing the audience for why is
it in 2013 and now in
2023 we aren't doing some of the things
that he talked about it's a really
interesting talk and that's the kind of
the point I'm trying to make here is
that we're moving into an era where
there's more solutions coming out
that's abstracting away complexity and
giving us these new kinds of platforms
so what I've been talking about in this
particular case is is called calyx
you can look it up at calyx.io
but I also I think I've also hopefully
covered things in a somewhat generic way
in you know in like generic about
microservices generic about a venture
and types of systems and about platforms
that are coming so it's it's not that
we're getting rid of kubernetes but by
far this platform that I'm talking about
calyx is built on top of kubernetes but
is kubernetes less from the perspective
of people using it this database list is
brokerless all those things are there
but they're abstracted away and they're
I think they're abstracted away quite
nicely and I'm really excited about you
know our future is you know as more and
more solutions like this come out so
thank you and um I think we're ready for
some questions if there are any
doesn't look like there's any questions
right now
um
you got my Twitter handle
down here the key H3 if you if you do
have any questions I'd be happy to
um
yeah try and handle those
um especially if you have people
watching the recording so I guess we
don't have any questions I'll turn it
back over to you Candace
thank you so much Hugh and thank you
everyone for joining us as a reminder
this recording will be on the Linux
foundation's YouTube page later today we
hope you join us for future webinars
have a wonderful day oh you know
actually it looks like we got
no I'm gonna hold off on on sending
everyone on the way it looks like we
might have gotten some q a oh yeah we do
oh yeah we got a bunch so yeah we want
to hang out and then we will like end in
about you know you can get through these
and once you're done we can wrap up
so the first question is uh have you
planned support for Apache mesos
um
not that I know of
um of course this system has to be able
to integrate with things that are
outside of this environment and
um and the two primary ways to do that
is either through you know uh through
message buses like Kafka or Google Pub
sub or something like that and then
through the apis you know either
external systems reaching into this you
know into applications you built here
with via the apis provided by the
services you build on this platform or
this you know actions within this
platform in your application reaching
out to external services
but no the the the
um the underlying I I deliberately
didn't say what is inside the Box you
know this this kalex box other than you
know things like yeah kubernetes is
there and there is a database and um you
know things like that but uh
pretty technology agnostic
um
the next question is do you think Helix
concepts are universally agreed upon
excellent question thank you I I think
yes and I did I kind of touched on that
in in that
um
especially in Building event-driven
microservice Systems
the the concepts are grounded in those
things we and like I said you know that
microservices we've been trying to uh
evangelize the concept of microservices
should be tight focused on their data
Loosely coupled and the one of the best
ways to Loosely couple microservices is
to do a venting because one service
emits events you know it's fire and
forget they the the the producer of
messages does not care who the consumers
are the consumers of messages does not
care who the producers are that's
Loosely coupled so the concepts I think
are heavily grounded in and where and
another thing I just real quickly is I'm
I'm saying especially in people that I
talk to out in all over the world
we're kind of going through a
generational shift in people that have
built some micro service systems that
weren't following some of these
principles and now event driven for
example is becoming much more popular
oh uh let's see
that looks like it for the questions
thank you for the um I'm glad some
people enjoyed it
um
give it a try there's a free trial you
can try it out we've you know I've got
my examples that I've been trying to
push out there
um it if you're interested in this kind
of stuff try for free it you know you
can do it on an individual basis
um it's rocked my world as a developer
I'll say that
um
we'll hear some more questions
um
oh this is a good question uh let's see
we just yeah we got a few more minutes
um how is this different from Dapper
excellent question uh Dapper is uh a
distributed application platform I think
is what it stands for it's from
microservices it's a really cool
solution definitely worth taking a look
because I I consider it to be similar in
some respects to calyx the big
difference is that what Dapper does is
it it straps away things at the code
level but it allows you to configure in
at the level below this code abstraction
layer that's provided by Dapper into
specific services so you are involved in
configuring in the services and you are
also responsible for running all those
services or somebody is that with calyx
that there's that hard layer that you
know you we calyx is a platform as a
service we provide the platform we
manage the platform for you we run it
there's nothing to configure you know
the services that are within calyx are
are defined
Dapper gives you that that the
flexibility to to do something uh you
know do it the way you want to do it so
it but it is I think they're they're
similar in a lot of ways in spirit
you know I see I think we get a little
bit more time
uh
is there any plans for a community-based
version it is a platform as a service
it's kind of like uh you know Amazon
serverless on steroids and if you look
at some of the other talks and other
materials we have we've kind of talked
about how we're
um we're in Spirit uh
similar to serverless but beyond that in
a way that because we're uh we're we're
not we're not just you know say
abstracting waves say the functionality
but we're abstracting away the data
layers and the messaging layers and
things like that
um but you know in both cases you're
you're running this on a platform that
you that you pay for
um
it it it does run in a um
in a uh dedicated environment you can
have a dedicated environment running in
Amazon or Google right now Microsoft
coming uh later uh later later this year
uh and um but no no plans for uh
Community version and then let's see
we've got one more
yeah somebody wanted to contact contact
like I said through
um through initially contact through
um Twitter would be great
um
and I think we're out of time so
no I guess let me finish this one let me
look for realization
yes sorry
trying to understand this last question
that's here is
um I couldn't find just Santa's Last
Question in your Apple music library you
can ask me to play a radio station or
ask a few music in a different app
I okay the last one I want to cover is
is it about how much percent it
increases the developer development time
and
it is but in it's not increases decrease
the
um
the developer I think
and I'm speaking this from my experience
as a developer writing code on the
system and then I've been writing code
for decades on many different platforms
all usually back in all
um mostly Java so that's kind of my
background back you know back-end
Enterprise systems
um it
decreases the time that I that I know
I've spent on development because I'm
eliminating the time that I spent on
non-development activities like
configuring in uh services like
understanding how to do you know
learning how to do new things like
kubernetes and uh Kafka and all these
other things I've done that but that you
know when you when you're new to that of
course you have to invest the time to do
that then invest the time to typically
have some involvement in setting it up
you know somebody that somebody
somewhere has to do this and often it
falls onto the development team
the thing I like about this is that now
like I was saying earlier that I'm
totally focused on
the design and implementation of this
it's like
trying to really reduce the friction
from the initial thoughts of design and
the initial lines of code all the way
into production make that that entire
process
much more frictionless that's the way I
view this so
and all focused on really features that
matter to the business features that
matter to your users not all the other
tasks that we typically have to deal
with in these highly complex
environments that we run around back in
applications
all right with that I'll I'll turn back
over to you Candace I think um
we've used up enough time for everybody
here
awesome thank you so much Hugh for your
time today and thank you everyone for
joining us a reminder that this
recording will be on the Linux
foundation's YouTube page later today we
hope you join us for future webinars and
have a wonderful day